Makeup and beauty products were the domains of women,...
...but with the new metrosexual movement, this might change.
Are cosmetics going to be the future for males?
Indications are that although the majority of men are still very resistant to the idea of applying makeup,...
...the general interest has been enough to keep the industry going.
About 1000 new products have been launched in the last few years.
Marketing has been quite successful, especially through renaming the products.
Terms like "makeup" and "cosmetics" were replaced by "corrective products for men",...
...along with terms like Improver, Enhancer, and Confidence Corrector.
With clients like Brad Pitt and Johnny Depp,...
...the most well - known product line is probably Menaji, but 4VOO is also very popular.
The good thing is that if you feel shy about buying these things in a department store,...
...all the products are also available online.